hi I'm John McLean only the Technical
Services team for from research in
Europe and my talk is going to be about
non-invasive cancer diagnosis using
cameras that you swallow and image
processing on the results that they
capture
hello everybody I'm John McLean I have a
range of things I'm involved in at
Wolfram research but one of my key roles
is that I lead the Technical Services
team in Europe so we have a group there
there does consulting projects using the
autumn technology for different outside
customers to tailor it to do what they
want most of that starts encumbered by
non-disclosure agreements that we sign
but so this particular one is publicly
funded so I can talk about it and so
this is a project that we're involved in
where it early stages on but we've
already got a couple of bits and pieces
I can show you but we're working over
the next year or two to try and improve
the Diagnostics of colon cancer so it's
fairly mild warning on here but I do
have a couple of pictures but I've kept
a little horrible gnarly pictures away
but let's let's set the theme first of
all which is that you know as you would
imagine in called bowel cancer it's kind
of a significant thing it accounts for
at least on the UK rates 26 deaths per
hundred thousand people years so that
scales are pretty fast in the UK 16,000
people a year die from bowel cancer in
the US that's 51,000 so it's a pretty
significant cause of death and
annoyingly it's highly treatable but if
it's detected early it's very treatable
and quite survivable but of course you
can't see what's going on deep inside
you so it tends to be that it only gets
diagnosed quite late and that's results
in deaths now there are some early signs
that trigger people to to look more
closely but in the end the only
diagnostic that is fairly definitive is
colonoscopy so there is this long camera
that is on a tube and it has a camera it
has some lighting it has some control
system up it so you can pilot the thing
and and you have to stick it deep inside
you to have a look around and and it
feeds back real-time pictures to the
person driving the thing as they
navigate around your bowel to have a
look at what's there now there's a bunch
problems with that one obviously it's
perversion people really don't like the
idea of that which of course puts people
off having early diagnostic
and that makes the outcomes worse it's
also got a real skilled problem that
you've got somebody's got to both pilot
and diagnose so there's and they have to
be there to do that so it's it's got a
quite a demand on the operator in order
to do this you can't just get some
random nurse to go and check you out it
actually takes some skill
it requires hospital facilities so
that's expensive you've got support
staff you've got rooms and it's actually
not without risk so there the current
rate is 0.5 percent 7 percent
perforation so you might be completely
healthy and after you come out from this
you've got a hole in your stomach
because the operator drove it badly and
poked it through your side of the bowel
wall so the rates not high these guys
are reasonably skilled but it's still
significant and so you might end up with
in the hospital stay even if there's
nothing to diagnose so here's the kind
of the the fresh idea that this project
that we're involved in with a whole
consortium of different partners is to
try and push forward the idea of the
capsule endoscopy so there's this pill
and I guess you can guess from the size
now I'm not sure quite sure the exact
sizes it's contains a fully
self-contained camera light and power
system and I believe even kind of Wi-Fi
is built into this thing and it makes
for fairly large pill but quite swallow
ball so it's patient friendly all you
have to be able to do is swallow a pill
you have to retrieve it afterwards but
you can do this in your own home in the
privacy of your own home in the comfort
of your own home there's no operating
you are the operator you just swallow
the thing sit around for a while there
you're given some some preparation to
help speed its journey got it finally
right euphemism but it's essentially
risk free but it still has a problem
which is that now instead of you know a
few minutes of real-time footage it
comes out with thousands of photographs
it's taking multiple frames a second at
its highest rated I think it's got some
detective whether it's moving so it
doesn't waste too many frames but it
comes out with thousands of frames which
need reviewing and that review is still
at this point a skilled process and
in a way it's worse now because you've
got these thousands of images whereas
before when you were controlling thing
if it look everything looks good you
kind of just send it in further and look
somewhere else so ultimately the course
what we want is to move towards fully
automated diagnostics you know the
promise here is that the machine
learning could just take this video and
give you the all-clear and you know it
might run for a few minutes as it runs
through the thousands of frames scores
them all and then tells you what the
outcome is and of course if you follow
that through that's that's an immediate
reduction in cost because you don't need
the skilled operator but it also it has
a knock-on effect then that it it can
scale much higher so first of all your
scaling is more images we can actually
get the entire digestive tract so you're
not limited to those places that you've
looked you can look everywhere literally
but also the promise here is that if in
fact this was cheap enough we could use
that diagnostic much more readily so
rather than waiting until there are some
very bad warning signs and deciding that
maybe a colonoscopy to check whether
it's spell cancer is needed it could
potentially even madonna's some kind of
routine middle-aged screening oh you
know you've hit the age of 50 is time
you you swallow the pill and then we'll
give you the all-clear for another
decade or or whatever and if we can
catch as said because it's one of these
cancers with early detection has good
outcomes getting it before it's it's
progressed actually could reduce a lot
of those deaths so that's the the
ultimate aim but with often that at this
point so you know with as with all
machine learning tasks pretty much the
Achilles heel is data we've got the
devices now but we don't really have the
training data so the project we're
involved in is about trying to deal with
some of the practicalities of how does
one run these things at scale and to try
and improve the process of reviewing
footage and to build training sets and
then use those to do automated machine
learning to then try and assist the
Diagnostics so there's a whole bunch of
stages that the aspirational goal is a
fully automate
to diagnosis all of Academy you hand it
in an hour later you get an email saying
everything's fine stage one we're
focusing on a review interface that
allows us to tag the images so a skilled
operator will still need to look at
everything we're trying to figure out
some ways to make it more convenient to
look at but the idea is here that
they're going to tag the this looks like
cancer this doesn't look like cancer and
build that training set so that we can
then go to stage two where essentially
the same kind of interface will be in
operation but instead of saying look at
frame 1 look at frame to look at frame 3
it'll now say here's the frames that
look worst and it'll you'll be able to
say show me the most dangerous looking
images first and you'll be able to mark
those up show me everything that's above
a 10% risk of looking like cancer maybe
look at a few of the ones that are
marked as clean to make sure they're
good but you know some prioritization so
we build this virtuous feedback loop of
the act of trying to use it for
Diagnostics improves the training sets
to improve the Diagnostics and
ultimately step towards this long-term
goal so let me show you the the first
prototype tool that we have so the video
has already been uploaded we're not
doing any kind of automated database
connection yet so it's file-based at
this point and the idea is here and
let's do the straightaway I'll do open U
and we'll pick a video file of that's
being captured and this is doing some
work now you can't see it but we've got
an asynchronous process going on here
going through that video and doing some
preparation work to set it up for this
next stage of the interface where where
we review the content so it's gonna have
a look here and where we've got so far
and you can see it's processed 431 of
the frames out of the 8600 but it's
still working in the background while
we're in this view review step and the
basic idea is I can go over the
thumbnails here and have a closer look
so here's we're looking down the length
of the bowel we're sort of facing
forwards this particular image has a big
bubble in the way but you can see the
the areas so this is this is an
obstructive bubble that's going on here
that's the direction of travel and then
this is battle wall we're seeing around
the outside and this review interface
then allows me to click on this image
and say well that one looks unclean or
maybe I'm unsure or it's clean or I can
select all of those and say they all
look good to me all look unclean to me
let's say and go on to the next page and
continue to review and so on so it's a
simple basic thing of pulling out the
frames setting them up so that there's a
fairly click process - - marking them
and then we've got an export where I can
write those files out - let's say my
desktop here and if we go across this
folders now just appeared and we've got
a data file here it's open it's in math
that's good so here is the data file
that shows the human classifications
that these things were marked as cancer
and I didn't have any of the day marks
it's not cancer this is dummy
information at the moment for the
machine learning classification that's
when we get the first classifier back
from the team working on the machine
learning this will start putting in the
its opinion and this is then all setup
ready for post analysis along with
folders of the images that have been
marked the match up to the IDS within
the data file so let's talk for a moment
all set helps I picked out what I
thought were the kind of key elements of
Wolfram language is helping us here so
the first step is we have a whole bunch
of process control we're using ffmpeg
for the video - image processing because
Mathematica doesn't currently support
MPEG video I'm very pleased to hear the
work of and pursue Marcus you're
involved in this how you know daddy's
work on on adding video functionality
because we plan to completely scrap this
one so once 12.1 gives us native
handling of video but at the moment what
we're doing is we're using start process
to start an asynchronous process of FM
MPEG taking the video and slicing up
into frames and writing them into a
folder where we can pick them up with
JPEGs and process status is allowing us
to watch how that's doing
now the tool is I have it there is doing
no real image processing it's um it's
just putting the images up on screen but
B so there's a line I always tell people
and when I talk to people about machine
learning for the first time I always
told them that machine learning is good
when you are data rich and understanding
poor and that sort of classical methods
are better when you are understanding
rich and data poor so while we're very
low on data there is a belief that that
the things that we can detect through
human intelligence and remove from the
image should be done to allow the
machine learning to be able to focus
only on the bits that we don't
understand which is what this cancer
look like so we do have some image
processing that we've been doing to
detect and remove the obstructions which
at least at the moment appear to be very
consistently recognizable so for example
the bubbles that we saw in that earlier
image seem to be about the only thing
going on down there on a relatively
clean stomach that have very high kind
of edge entropy and so we've used that
kind of characteristic to be able to
pick out the area that looks like
bubbles and take an image and D bubble
it so we can mask out those areas that
we think are obscuring anything that's
worth seeing and we got the same thing
with with unclean where there is sort of
blockages that they're finding that
color seems to be a pretty good
indicator that the bowel wall is
generally fairly pink and the things
that get in the way from you seeing it
generally and not fairly pink so with a
little bit of contrast and color
detection we're able to pick out some of
those obstructions so this is some of
the auto filtering to try and take the
image and mask away the bits that aren't
actually any use for detection because
we're not actually seeing bowel wall and
you know their varying success sometimes
a little bit over conservative at the
moment but the idea is that we're gonna
try having this pre-filtering
so the machine learning is only ever
looking at bowel I don't actually have
any with me and I thought on the basis
of I didn't need to show anything on
this Sony Grimm I would just show the
pair my own pictures but basically they
they are I believe they're they're sort
of fairly small and nodules that
that have a kind of profile so they're
sort of a polyp that grows out of the so
they stick out albeit they have a bit of
shape but they also are colored a little
bit differently we don't know that at
this point so we're gonna try and find
you in these things it may I mean in the
long run in with enough data
of course the machine learning should
learn that bubbles don't ever affect the
outcome and we'll filter them out of
itself so this is thought as an
intermediate thing and when we're
playing around with that but the the the
pilots gathering data and really kicked
off yet so the machine learning team is
just kind of waiting and they're giving
us these hypotheticals on this small set
of data that we have to work from at the
moment we're speeding things up with
paralyzation so we have the usual
parallel tools where we can get through
many more of these processes in parallel
talking straddie it sounds like a lot of
the the video map type functionality
because we're not going through this
loop of writing an jpeg to read the jpeg
into do something to avoid jpeg out the
pipeline of throughput might be fast
enough that we can dispense with
parallel but we're leaving it in for the
moment anyway because the ultimate goal
of course is some really scalable
diagnostic system so you want to have
some big amazon cluster potentially
having thousands of patients uploaded to
it paralyzation to make sure you're not
waiting weeks for the answer might still
be important so the jury's out on that
part of course the thing you were seeing
it's it's all just standard dynamics so
we've got event handlers and tooltips
and buttons for the forward and back and
an import and export being driven by by
buttons and yeah these alters is just a
CDF like everything else that we do
pretty much and then it's a data
processing element that young we've seen
there but as we go into production the
system we have to deal with has an
elaborate patient record mechanism and
we need to be able to read that in
augment it with the the either the
automatic supposed detections or the
manual markups and write that thing back
into the into that system
that's all XML based so we're going to
be using things like XML element and
export strings be able to take what you
saw there is in a bunch of associations
and write them into the appropriate XML
structure and we can have to deal with a
bunch of the OAuth type or
authentication or database integration
tools be able to read and write directly
at the moment we're just being sent
files backwards and forwards so that's
the project I should wrap by going
credit where it's due the consortium is
quite large so we're at the moment
taking care of this user interface and
image processing side but not the
machine learning but there is a
following stage that we hope will get
funded we're there in fact there is a
separate machine learning problem for
trying to figure out who who will
benefit and I mean that both on a local
level for the individual that there
there may be characteristics about
certain patients will benefit more from
this than the traditional method but
it's not clear that that's that's true
but also into and I on a macroscopic
level that which hospitals will benefit
if you've got really efficient
colonoscopy teams then the cost benefit
might not be worth the switch and what
we want to do is to use the datasets on
both both descriptive logic of things
like costs and and benefits together
with patient level data to to be able to
start making predictions about the cost
and the benefits trade-off for
individual patients and then on on on
high level the lead on this is sure it's
met who you might know from he writes on
the blog and community occasionally
particularly about about Bayesian
statistics and he's done most of the
work on this
I've been slightly more hands-off with
design and sort of brainstorming but the
coding zorbing sherds
we're working with corporate health
international who are dealing with fee
the capsules a whole bunch of NHS bodies
so Arden and Jem Highland Health Board
Highland Islands and well so Highland
health Borden Selden and Jem are
commissioning bodies of the National
Health Service in the UK barcelona's
University are providing the machine
learning team and then we've getting
some extra of kind of facilitation
support and particularly money from from
the satellite catapult and the
enterprises
funding bodies within the UK so the
teams kind of quite big in spalling but
we've got our little bit of it which
you've seen the first steps off here
today and that's all I had to share with
you are there any questions
[Applause]